I figured since women can paint their
boobs and show them on Instagram yeah I
should be able to paint my dick and do
whatever I want true so I put together
this this like cyclist suit with
you know like the spandex shirt your
ten-speed bike and the helmet and we
just painted on the shorts like straight
black paint so I can go cruising around
like riding this bicycle I'm crashing it
in front of people and they're like oh
are you okay they reach other handle
everything up and I've just got my
schlong so we got me on all decked out
and you know the the costumes looks
hilarious and I took a photo
like hoisting up the bike a text this
photo to Knoxville and he writes back
that's the smallest black dick I've ever
seen so funny about those when the girls
do that like they paint on jeans and
well anybody notice in a store if a
girl's and asshole are out and
it's always like at first like look no
one notices he goes by the second store
they always notice because their
and asshole look like the Ultimate
Warrior's face and the WrestleMania the
natural disasters
[Music]
we have a video we want to watch of
little you know lil boosie is he's a
rapper I was on I've heard the name
before I don't know who he is but on
WorldStarHipHop today they had a video
of him I guess a frequent news worsening
every day I'm pretty sure I could plant
information on WorldStarHipHop that Jay
would believe his news I'll come down
there if you put on the only thing the
only footage I've ever washed if Donald
Trump is when I click the video says
Donald Trump up again s MH
popping off at the mouth Obama going ham
on Syria well how far these fans are
willing to go to get your attention this
made me laugh cuz i don't know if i
would normally click this except it was
in the uncensored part so what is this
girl gonna do
she's got fake lips right mean yeah but
this is great little boost he's a rapper
he's talking on instagram live to this
girl and he just everything about her
voice a white girl with a hip-hop thing
and then revealing her body this
hilarious sort of weird mom body she has
all the voices just guests on the voice
before he sees her like this
my pussy's thuggish you gotta bail oh
you already know you already know oh
yeah now this was thought and then
after going Darlene Darlene the
Camry is blocking me not wrong I don't
want ya it's more I think it's
definitely southern white car that for
sure well let's all take our temperature
when you will join wait pause it by the
way wait pay attention for some key
words here
Boomhauer from you've never
never had the nerve to get out and
introduce myself
you could there's a good tie in to Theo
von you know Theo
he was just in her last video cuz a
pedophile that she brings 4head yeah
lover I've gone 1 II know we came out
first thing what a horrible thing it was
that this young girls act like this and
she never actually then society just
made her a bazillionaire and now my
steering into it I like her now
it's crazy
large venues someone that just did a
very half soul to Albany funny bone no
one wants to catch me
it anywhere and the staffed out the
staff tells you goes I wasn't your fault
duty goes your you're competing
with Bertolli this week ahead behave
ease in town baby
also there's there's a giveaway at
Toyota there's a Toyota thong going on
is also a toy I used to get the worst
ones because I'm sorry there's nobody
here this weekend for the knee of the
shows now it's five-year are there's
there's the Pumpkin Festival this
weekend indian dude you're dealing with
Honda's deals days of summer ago it's
December they go he starts asking her
about if things are real and one of the
things she says a real or her eyes what
she goes my eyes real to people be
asking that all the time
he's ever girl goes la people think I've
glass eyes but but this to this girl
this is her shot at the big time this is
her gained audience with little
boo see you want to sit down with the
little booty I'm saying his name right
loosey-goosey faq lil boosie well let's
see what the he tease is this is just
another Tuesday for him what are we
watching
I don't know Instagram live I think this
is a murder video a wacky white girl and
somehow got little boo C to just take
her is on Instagram live when your
Instagram Lobby window I don't know
think you can that's what's happening
here so this is like a direct person
that he accepted and I think it's like a
naked odd white woman who I like when
they talk to you also or not to you but
see this guy when they talk to the
celebrities like that like just that
goes did you get I don't know if you got
it cuz I sent you a box of my hair yeah
last month you get six months were you
getting my envelope of toenails so
little booties on top he's a guy I guess
a well-known rapper and the girl
underneath is a fan of his it's got his
attention and he is nonchalantly just
starts to ask her to do weird things she
is like oh yeah is that would you okay
and start doing bizarre do you think she
gets snake
before the call ordering buddy she's
naked already that's what I'm saying
she's currently naked you should put on
down and she goes no I'm still here hold
on worldstar just goes ahead and shows
everything well to let you know that
it's not safe for work
I'll gotcha I'll tell you what it's all
safe for what I'm taking a when I'm
watching you know my laptop meanwhile
Christine thinks you're just in there
talking to a southerner wishes I was
jerking off everything real it's real
it's all real does it suck your
suck your thumb like a child funny if
you're a guy like sleeping in the room
next to it you're just hearing this loud
it's just clean is it clean she
just keeps sniffing her Oh buzzy for
she's his arse she's fingering her
and then sucking on it yes oh god he
goes that's how you know no little
ism number 423 you guys suck y'all
that's how you know clean he's ripping a
huge blunt which the second I
got high I would just see all the
silliness in this and every like you
should go put on some clothes yeah lady
what are you doing right now she's
sucking on her look like her
lexapro bottle she's sucking on a
travel-size Listerine okay that's the
first
[Music]
exactly the same ain't one better the
other doctor says I got a lazy butt hole
that's what you know back up what is he
saying he's bobbing his head
I came before this who's giving all the
hugs this is definitely public who's
given all the heart Oh Stacy two five
six low per your anus is very clean up
mark I mean dude that's crazy that
other people are watching this on
Instagram live just why how
could you look away from it no but I'm
saying like commenting just being like
supportive like a good bubble
right that does look clean I think her
eyes fake though okay I didn't catch
that
so are we good for tickets plus three or
is it though everybody's name was it
will call I just don't want to show up
if I'm supposed to have something
printed out you got to tell me before I
leave the house oh yeah Bootsy I hate to
do this because I know you're in a car
with some friends I get I showed you my
butthole
I'm just wondering if I can get two kids
to me it's me instagramming boozy hey a
little boozy Dan Soder let me show you
my butthole real quick so are those good
for tickets man who the is you what
is she saying this white boy show me as
hairy as asshole little boozy are we
cool okay your tickets dying all day you
get a gumbo recipe in my butthole that's
like that three months of rising goes
yell member that bitch from we met that
girl Haley goes I remember who Hale he
goes Haley man in the North
Carolina leg of the tour no one gets the
respect you get also he has such
hanging up with my grandma own when he
goes okay okay okay
everything's and he's gone okay I'll see
you when I'm there yes done a little bit
of editing yes to me that's like
Appetite for Destruction that's the
whole thing's perfect look I don't like
Paradise City one so be good take
another you don't watch parts of The
Godfather
ah that's just that girl I love
that she's like I got Bootsy tickets
today my eyes real before you ask
arribada ask her by to ask all the time
but no one did ask no one asked that day
her narrator yeah no one ever asked to
see her it was always her like
butthole we will take our last break
we're hanging out with steve-o we think
we found her well we did we did ladies
and gentlemen we got black Lou is doing
everything he can
the Internet is an amazing place that
you can just find a girl who showed a
rapper her butthole on worldstar stuck
on her finger that's her trait that's a
diss so y'all know my and bajo
clean I'll keep it clean it'd be great
if she went to do it then just winced
once without knowing it sorry
you've now that computer yeah
that kid this computers tomorrow they're
gonna boot it up this is given by it's
gonna look like at the loading a program
from the 80s less Christine looking for
Alabama yeah oh my god the show
before us was hiring escorts it shut up
we got her choice talks to TiVo nice how
is this this Haley do we have Haley on
the line Haley oh yeah we're uh how's it
goin Haley knew him for real it is
certainly Steve Oh for real and I have
just viewed your butthole
[Music]
you